pour moi je dirais le féminicide c'est
la négation de la scène lyrique et
[Musique]
cassandre et son ami ont rien randonnait
dans un village argentin quand elles
sont tombés dans un guet-apens
les étudiantes ont été battues violées
et tuées revoir ces images c'est une
illustration encore renouvelé qu'on la
nie ça ça reste on la nie cassandre en
allier orillas 1
on les a tuées
guirec omd comme des moins que rien
les argentins ont un mot pour qualifier
ce genre de crimes contre les femmes le
féminicide interne qui a frappé jean
michel bouvier au point de vouloir
introduire cette notion dans le droit
français
ce féminicide finalement serait traité
comme un crime contre l'humanité mais
hunting ne vise qu'une ou deux personnes
la tribune elle avait pour but à la fois
de crier je dirais ma douleur mais en
même temps d'essayer je dirais que la
société s'empare de la spécifiques et
des droits je dirais féminin au travers
du concept de féminicide cassandre jean
michel bouvier mènera ce combat il veut
interpeller les candidats à la
présidentielle sur les pires violences
faites aux femmes
[Musique]
sur sur le fond du dossier féminicide
j'ai pas eu de réponse la société
n'était pas prête a de ce point de vue
là là là je vois une accélération
[Musique]